The team is calling this stupid. Why are
you not on the team, Hutch? The entire
team is calling this stupid, man. Wake
up. The Nazi tattoo is nowhere near as
bad. You bald [__]
Off. No. No. No. Fantasy. That didn't
happen. Nope. It's not a genocide.
All right. Do we want to get into this
Hutch segment? So Hutch watched or was
about to watch a Kyle My whole life.
>> This is a video from Kyle Kolinsky on
the backlash to voting for Platner. This
is a his oxen claus video. Yeah, his
Aenclaus video. Okay, we've talked about
the subject already. Do any of are any
of you guys unaware of Jake Oenclaus,
the Massachusetts House of
Representatives member who basically
said he couldn't in good conscious like
vote for Graham Platner
and basically said that he wouldn't be
able to do that and really didn't keep
it restricted to the primary and then
came out later and tried to walk it back
to just being about the primary, but it
really wasn't about the primary. He was
kind of saying forever. That happened
like 3 days ago. So, that's what the
video is about with Kyle. And we're
going to watch Hutch go through it
because I do think Hutch has effectively
in in a lot of ways seemingly walked
back the blue no matter who thing to the
uncommitted position
or at least one where he doesn't feel
comfortable criticizing the uncommitted
position, which is insane. Okay, given
how much he's basically spent all of his
time in political advocacy for the past
year and a half on people who were
uncommitted in 2024,
right? And now he's essentially getting
to the point where he's saying it's
wrong to criticize these people.
>> Check in with Kyle Kolinsky again. We
watched one of his videos yesterday, but
this is a topic that I think we should
probably talk about a little bit. So,
there's a uh a Democrat
in Massachusetts
who came out and said that he doesn't
think the party should support Platiner.
We're technically still in a primary,
but also the primary is effectively
over. And so, there's a lot of anger
being directed at this particular
Democrat for not being blue no matter
who kind of a thing. Even though
technically we're still in the
primaries, the conversation to me is
necessary and important right now
because
I just think we need to be mindful of
the optics.
Uh, and I think the optics of
>> Uhhuh.
>> of guilt tripping a man. What are the
optics of supporting anybody without
even looking into it? Supporting anybody
who is still like an open and avowed
Zionist. What are the optics like there?
Hutch optics should be pretty bad there.
No,
personally I feel like supporting all of
the dying in Lebanon right now is far
far far worse.
And having a tattoo, a Nazi tattoo even.
Are we really we're going to hand ring
over a Nazi tattoo when realistically
this is about Israel? It is again about
Israel. That is what it's going to be.
Again, I do believe that's where Kyle's
video goes. Okay, man. It's
>> over not wanting to support a candidate
who had a Nazi tattoo. Like the optics
are so bad.
Um, when
Rashida Talib didn't endorse Kamla,
I told my chat at the time and I meant
that. I'm like, I'm not gonna give her
for that. you know, I'm just I I'm not,
you know, she has family in Gaza, so
it's a really emotionally charged kind
of issue for her. And, you know, is it
really the end of the world if she
didn't endorse?
Um,
I caution people against that kind of
stuff because it's like, you know, it's
just the optics are not great. Um, that
was a really kind of tough pitch during
the the Biden campaign and the Kala
campaign, but it's the same kind of
logic here. Like, I don't think we
should be up in arms calling for the
resignation of a Democrat because he's
uncomfortable endorsing a guy who had a
Nazi tattoo for like 15 years and
definitely at some point became aware
that it was a Nazi tattoo. He's just
Hutch. Hutch does this now, guys. It's
blue no matter who, but like Nazi
tattoo, Nazi tattoo, Nazi tattoo, Nazi
tattoo. Every argument he's ever made.
Like the vast majority of his coverage
of Graham Platner has been complaining
about Graham Platner in the exact way he
complained about all of the uncommitted
people attacking Kl over over Gaza and
over Israel. It's like the he's followed
every single one of the steps they went
through
even after giving all of his criticism.
And I just don't get it. I just don't
get it. He's just obviously lying about
that. If I lived in Maine, I would
support Platner. If you live in Maine, I
think you should vote for Platner. I
think winning a Senate majority is
bigger than any one candidate, even in
the most extreme circumstances like this
one. What's worse, a Nazi tattoo or
Trump?
Well, uh, it's a little bit different
talking about like the Senate here.
>> It's a little Wait, it's a little
different. What? And well, uh, it's a
little bit different talking about like
the Senate here, but
>> yeah, it's like talking about who has
the Senate majority, you eggheheaded. Oh
my god,
dude. This is so stupid. It's a Senate
seat. It's It is It's critically
important. Okay, it's critically
important.
Anyways, they're you know, they're going
nuts over this one candidate. For my
whole life, we've heard from
establishment slashcorporate slash
centrist.
>> Also, I'm I'm I'm already becoming
furious right now because
you get to you get to go complain about
blue no matter who if you were blue no
matter who.
No, wrong.
You're trying to get the people who
weren't blue, no matter who, on your
side, you stupid. So when you stop
entertaining it after getting them on
your side, you look stupid.
How is that hard to understand? You are
trying to get people who were not blue
no matter who to be in a blue no matter
who. And then you are flip-flopping on
that ideal the first moment it becomes
even a tiny bit inconvenient for you.
It's disgraceful, frankly.
You know what I mean? If you were
actually blue no matter who, then I
think you have you at least you were
consistent.
If you if you if you haven't been blue
no matter who in the past, I don't think
you have any right to be giving this
guy.
>> At the end of the day, you have to vote
blue no matter who. Even if you don't
like the candidate, even if you know
they disagree with you on one or two
issues, even if they're like big issues,
honestly, even if they disagree with you
on like eight or nine issues, um you
really have no choice. You kind of got
to suck it up and vote for the Democrat
no matter what because the Republicans
are so bad that uh you really have no
choice here. There's Kyle being blue no
matter who
based patriot Kyle Kolinsky. Listen, no
matter how bad it is, you got to vote
blue. You got to do it. You got to do
it, man. Come on, man. Look, that's a
that's a line of reasoning that I was
very very skeptical of. Namely because
it just felt like there are way too many
Democrats who don't actually fight for
Democratic policies or what are supposed
to be Democratic policies in the past.
Everybody knows this. I've gone back and
forth between voting for Democrats and
voting for third parties or sitting out
an election. Um but I must say that what
>> back and forth I mean Okay. Well,
>> watching this MAGA crime
>> in this segment where Hutch is
entertaining going back and forth where
he's saying, "Well, don't don't like try
to get people back in line who are
falling away from Blue no matter who."
He goes, "Oh, Kyle was back and forth.
What an idiot."
>> Uh, didn't vote for Hillary, didn't vote
for Biden. Has he said if he voted for
KL? He claims he supported her, which is
that word is doing a lot of leg work. I
honestly the level of contradiction that
Hutch operates in on a base level is
very interesting to me. Like does he not
understand that his job is supposed to
be like getting people to vote Democrat?
Like convincing people to vote Democrat,
but he actually just spends all of his
time on people who are like entertaining
the idea and who have massive audiences.
Like basically representing some sort of
some sort of establishment Democrat, but
in the worst way and least inviting way
possible. like he is just the he is like
the essence of of like Democrat elitism.
You didn't you didn't vote for Hillary.
You didn't vote for Biden. Uh why are
you even here? What would you even say
you're doing here? It's like dude work.
But did he ever say that he straight up
voted for Kla? I don't even know. truly
has sort of opened my eyes to the wisdom
of vote blue no matter who because I I
feel like my hesitancy to do that
really stemmed from a lack of
imagination as to how truly evil and
horrific the Republican party is.
Lack of imagination. Excuse me. Why? You
didn't even need to imagine anything. It
It's been really bad. for years. It's
been really bad for years and years and
years.
>> I think a lot of people had no idea how
bad this second term would be. Like I
think a lot of people are overwhelmed
with how bad this second term is. Like
in your wildest dreams, it didn't seem
like it would go this crazy. I'm telling
you, like nobody really thought in their
heart of hearts it would be like this.
If it was just a second version like 10%
up from Trump 1, like that's
lightweight. You know what I mean? This
is like 10x. This is like 20x Trump won.
It's crazy.
>> He's saying things had to get as bad as
they've gotten after the 2024 election
for him to realize, okay, the
Republicans are actually pretty bad, so
I need to do blue no matter who. Bro,
they've been really, really bad for
years. Like once you truly digest that
the Republican party is a fascist
terrorist imperialist death cult, and
they are,
>> you would do like literally anything to
stop them. like anything and everything
from the softest tactics to the hardest
tactics. You can and should do all of
that. Okay,
>> dude. That's uh that's like bordering
that's getting close to stochcastic
stuff, is it not? The hardest tactics
and you should do all of them. It's like
he's going to have to he he if he's
smart, he walks that back slightly.
Okay, so as I've gotten older, I
understand more where that mindset of
like vote no matter who comes from,
right? I used to think it was sort of
stupid blind party loyalty. Now I see
it's like oh no I get it. It's because
these are so evil and so insane that to
do anything that even in an ancillary
way helps them is atrocious. Okay. Now
>> some of us have been begging you people
to understand this for years. Some of us
have been begging you for years to
understand this.
>> Here's the thing though. All of those
people who said vote blue no matter who
and screamed that from the rooftops for
my whole life. The second that leftwing
Democrats started actually winning
primaries they immediately abandoned
that immediately. That listen now you
want to talk about Hutch just did a
little, you know, self- congratulations.
Maybe I'd do a little self-
congratulations here as well and say,
"Who told you that the second somebody
won a primary, second a lefty candidate
won a primary, you'd see people pull
away." Who said that? That's happening
for sure, 100%. Just be ready for it.
Don't even be Don't even be a little
thrown off by it cuz it's going to
happen. You just have to rise above it,
okay? You got to be better. So, let's
jump forward and go to where Hutch comes
back from the bathroom
>> and he invites Josiah in
>> and said,
>> uh, there were a couple of people in my
replies yesterday or the day before
about Jake Aenclauss, but there was no D
vida. Um, but yeah, I did spar with some
people yesterday.
>> Yeah. So, what what was your position on
that whole thing? So, just for the
backstory chat, he again he's a
Massachusetts Democrat American.
Um, and said
like it went beyond kind of skepticism,
right? Didn't he say something al it was
pretty strong?
>> He said he couldn't conscient it, right?
Couldn't good conscious endorsement.
>> Wrong statement. He said something along
the lines of, you know, there shouldn't
be.
>> He said he was disqualified.
>> Yeah. Yeah. There should alen clause.
Yeah.
>> Right. About platinum for for the um for
for the Nazi tattoo, I imagine.
>> And uh Yeah. But what was your take on
that?
>> Uh my take is vote blue no matter who
applies here. So if Graham Platner is
the nominee I mean he's the presumptive
nominee now he will be the nominee but
once he is the nominee Aenclaus needs to
shut the up and get behind him.
>> So be honest Josiah Aenclaus need to
shut the up already right like obviously
Josiah has been arguing that Aenclaus
should have shut the up already. Like
you could you could I think Josiah said
that you know Aenclaus could say well I
support this other guy in the primary
but I'll get behind the the damn
candidate. That would be the wording
right? I support this guy in the primary
but I'll get behind the damn candidate
is what you say right? Who thinks the
primary won't go to Platner? Nobody.
Literally nobody thinks that. Everybody
knows it's going to Platiner. It's not
close. It's not happening.
>> I think that's bold. I think that's a
bold that's a bold thing.
I I guess like
you know me, I'm I'm I I'll bite the
bullet on some crazy thought experiments
for Blue no matter who. But even during
the 2024 election when
>> Talib
again,
>> not endorsing Kamla, I didn't really
like criticize her all that much for it.
In fact, I I told my chat I like I'm not
going to, you know, the optics of that
are like really bad. Um like for
example, would you
first criticize her after it? So let's
say there was a
>> well hang on just a just a couple of
things right there. So listen if your if
your standard is consistent and listen
it's actually vote no vote blue no
matter who with an asterisk. So you have
the same rule for aen claus as you do to
lead that's fine that's consistent. Um
I'm so horny for a democratic senate
majority that you know my position was
like for example like during the 2024
campaign I supported the uncommitted
movement in the primary trying to
pressure you know president Biden and
Vice President Harris to move on Gaza in
exchange for their votes. I think it's
perfectly fair to try to leverage your
vote in a primary, but my position was
after the primary was over, um, you
know, if you were a Palestinian
American, an Arab American, a Muslim
American, um, and you felt that what was
going on was Josiah always is very like
prepared because he does his videos all
the time. Like he's always got, it's
almost like he's written out talking
points for himself every single time.
It's very interesting to listen to him
come on to streams. Like you could tell
he's not even talking to Hutch, he's
like convincing Hutch's audience, right?
Like I feel like when he comes on to
talk sometimes it he is talking to the
other person but it's like with a set of
talking points that he's ready to
convince the audience too.
>> Was a genocide facilitated and funded by
the Biden administration even if he had
family members um you know who were
impacted by what's going on in Gaza. I'm
I'm not unsympathetic to that but I
think that you should still vote for the
Democrats, right? And so, you know, by
my lights here, um, if you are a
American, um, and my you should vote
for, uh, you should vote for Graham
Platner. And furthermore, if you're Jake
Aenclaus, who is not just a American and
not just a voter, but a Democratic
leader and a congressman, then I think
the standard is even higher in the sense
that, you know, you have an even bigger
duty, greater affirmative duty to back
Platner if Platner is the nominee. And
had Jake Aenclaw said either in his
statement or in his clarifying statement
because he got a lot of from a lot of
people including a lot of centrists like
Ron Felcowski of Midas Touch he's no
like you know um hippie liberal or
hippie progressive right this is a
former Republican who's the
editor-inchief of Midas touch he even
read uh Aenclaus the riot act if
Aenclaus had said look I would prefer
Costello in the primary or for Janet
Mills to unsuspend her campaign and come
back Um, but I will back whoever the
Democratic nominee is in Maine. I'd be
fine with that. But that's not what he
said. And thus my frustration with Aen
Clauss, who I otherwise like, like I've
done videos every time Aenclaus has been
on my channel in terms of content of
coverage. Um, you know, it's it's pretty
glazing cuz he is an excellent debater,
excellent communicator. He's a veteran.
Um, he's basically like a younger Pete
Budajge, probably more moderate than
Pete Budajage. Um, but yeah, he really
let me down with this one.
Yeah,
I I understand that. Um especially when
the stakes are so high. Um
>> Okay. Do you understand your own
position? The position you obviously
should have had. Okay. All right.
>> If there was Let's let me deise a
thought experiment. if if there was a a
more obscure
KKK kind of symbol cuz cuz like the
toten conf like I I was familiar with it
but not the wait the the symbol doesn't
matter here it's just are do you agree
with the principle
right
cuz Hutch you've been arguing this
principle that it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what your small petty
disagreements are right and every
disagreement by the way even if even if
you're disagree agreement was on
segregation. It's a small petty
disagreement to not support or not like
get these people into the party. You
should maximize seats. This is the
entire idea behind your
pro-segregationist argument. So, quote
unquote, right? That even if they have
really reprehensible views, they should
be brought into the party if they can
win.
Like it it's not super wellknown
um as much as like the swastika for
example. Um,
>> if there was if there was like a KKK
like symbol that had that was analogous
that that was that was known to people
who knew like studied history but not
necessarily like the lay person wouldn't
necessarily like bought it and and and a
candidate was discovered to have had one
of the same exact situation. You know,
military person got a tattoo at a parlor
in Croatia.
Okay, just say if the hutch just the
platiner situation,
>> you know, claims to not have known after
>> he this is another thing where like he's
trying to drive home just how bad it is.
He he does this quite a lot, right?
There's no reason not to say the
platiner situation, but he wants to say
like Nazi Nazi Nazi Nazi Nazi Nazi Nazi
Nazi Nazi Nazi Nazi that and again if he
wants to if he wants to really die on
this hill that having some principled
opposition to a politician is okay,
which is my position. He wants to die on
that hill, then just die on that hill.
Just say that's the position.
>> Whatever. Like literally just one to one
same thing. Can you imagine yourself
tell um like telling a black voter or a
black Democrat like railing against a
black Democrat for like I guess my
position is like well I kind of get it
in that particular case. I'm not going
to do
>> we have to go through it again.
>> You're saying that if if we had like for
example like one or thankfully there are
no emerging segregationist Democrats.
I'm happy to entertain your
hypothetical, but even if we were to do
this hypothetical,
>> ridiculous.
>> Like you're saying that like let's say
like one or two like segregationist
Democrats emerge and all of a sudden
they were competitive in like Nebraska
or Missouri. You're saying that us
adding that to like get a Senate
majority would be worse than the MAGA
movement right now in terms of like like
it's actually crazy. Senate majority,
Senate majority, Senate majority. Dude,
>> I think it would be I think it would
make the the So, if I believed
empirically it would help stop Trump, I
would encourage you to vote for them.
But we just have a different uh thought
process on the empirics. So the empirics
are that I think and I think so is
convinced that allowing segregationist
in the Democratic party would uh like
hurt mid to long-term results in the
brand of the Democrats that it would
worsen our chances to
do you guys that like like black civil
rights leaders when they were you know
deciding who they wanted to. So again,
Soyel has this position, right, where
it's like, oh, long term, you could
think about it. And Hutch could
entertain that position if he likes, but
unfortunately for him, there now is no
other way to you either like you should
be honest about what your position is.
If you're entertaining the soy pill
position, it should be we oppose Graham
Platner because Graham Platner will hurt
this party long term and we will give up
a Senate majority right now. like our
chance at a Senate majority, we will
throw it away because bringing Grand
Platinum. If you just sit there and hand
ring about it and weigh this guy down or
or support weighing this guy down while
not actually taking a strong position,
you're just a
but pick a lane, man. Pick a lane and
drive to the basket, okay? Don't don't
sit here hand ringing. You can't sit
here in the middle and go, "Well, I
understand some people wanting to
undercut him." But, you know, I guess I
guess I would say vote for him, but I
don't want to criticize people who don't
want to vote for him and want to rail
against him, but also all I'm going to
talk about are his negatives every
single time he comes up. Uh-huh. Pick
pick a lane, man. Pick a lane. Okay.
We're on this one or this one or this
one.
>> Kind of like hard on that one. Yeah.
>> Well, no. I I kind of get it, too. I I
kind of got it when again Palestinian
Americans didn't want to pull the lever
for Biden or Harris. I kind of I kind of
get it with voters uh having their
reservations about Graham Platner. I
would kind of get it in the hypothetical
you describe. But again, I think at the
end of the day, you know, unless because
here's the other thing too where I would
bite the bullet is if we had actually
compelling evidence to believe that
Graham Platner was a Nazi, I would
probably have to revisit my Okay, how
much do you really want the Senate
majority decide? you know, do you if
Graham Platner is a Nazi and he just has
a little D next to his name, you know,
is he really preferable to Susan
Collins? Um, like I would I I don't know
if I would be as committed as I am now.
I just, you know, I don't I don't
believe that Graham Platner is a Nazi. I
don't think you believe Graham Platner
is a Nazi. I don't think Jake Aenclaus
believes that Graham Platner is a Nazi.
And Jake Aenclaus isn't just a voter.
Again, he is a he is a a House of
Representatives member, a member of the
Democratic Party who understands the
fight voter who also happens to be a
Democratic leader who leads or is is
part of an organization called
Democratic majority and it's going to be
very very hard for us to get a
Democratic majority I suppose is
possible if we lose Maine. But Maine is
one of the easier gets based on the
current landscape. So again, my standard
for Aenclaus like while I would have
more sympathy for just I suppose a
random voter my my position Aenclaus
would be sir with all due respect um you
have a duty here to the party in the
country and you're not just a random
voter and again if you want to say you
would prefer Costello in the primary
because of uh you know Graham Platner's
past the tattoo the comments fair enough
but you have an affirmative duty to the
party in the country to get behind
whoever the Democratic nominee is and he
has not committed to doing that. And
that's again what
>> let's just hope Platiner isn't another
Federman. Well, the unfortunate thing
with Federman is that he has a like
cataclysmic brain injury that they put
him back in Congress with. So
>> that's why I say, you know, he's not
just getting from Kyle and Crystal Ball
and whoever. He's getting from mightest
touch liberals.
>> No, no, I Yeah, I understand. No, but in
my thought experiment, could you imagine
yourself like telling a telling a black
Democrat to, hey, listen, suck it up. We
got you got we got to take back the
Senate. I'd probably try to be polite
about it, but yeah. Yeah.
>> I don't know.
>> But again,
I understand. I understand. And listen,
fair enough. As long as you're
consistent. What what I don't with are
people again cuz like there were some
people in the in the conversation
yesterday and Doss Vidan may have been
one of them who were like, "Well,
when because I use the Kla Harris
example, I'm sorry. It's the shot. It's
the shot. You expected Palestinian
Americans to set aside their Yeah. You
know, I had a I had a family member
blown apart in Gaza.
>> Why is he putting black people on a
pedestal? I don't know. Maybe for a lot
of people, I think it's just something
that
most people understand how to look at
race relations in a way that like, hey,
something's clearly unfair there. It it
does sort of it creates like a bright
line for people where they might not be
clear when it's other topics. So, I do
understand bringing it up sometimes
because of a war that Biden and Harris
funded and you expected me to pull the
the the lever for Biden and Harris, then
yeah, I'm sorry. The the the tattoo is
infinitely less egregious than an actual
humanitarian crisis.
Who said that? Who said that it's
infinitely less? Who said Yeah. Okay.
Nazi tattoo versus a bunch of kids in
Lebanon. Still, by the way, still still,
wait, that's current support, but this
would be about Yeah. versus the Kla
thing, which was still a genocide going
on. Come on, man. Come on, dog.
>> Which is being facilitated in part by
the Biden administration. And I did
expect Arab and Muslim Americans to vote
for Kla Harris or Joe Biden. Cuz that's
the other thing. Well, Kla Harris wasn't
in charge of foreign policy, so you
can't hold that against her. Yeah, but I
also had that standard when Biden was
the nominee, too. If you want to use the
uncommitted movement to pressure him in
the primary, that's fine. But at the end
of the day, if the choice is between him
and Trump, you I still think you should
back Biden.
>> I do think they're different, though. I
I I don't I don't think they're quite
the same thing at all. Um you mentioned
it already, but VPs don't control
foreign policy. So, the fact the fact
that Kla Harris inherited all that
baggage, I felt
betrayed a kind of like something.
>> I'm sorry.
>> Was she also was she against the all the
operation? Did she distance herself? Did
she come out and say actually I I
strongly disavow this? She do anything
to distance herself or say that she was
it was against like her conscience or
anything or even just take like a a
positive stance towards stopping the
genocide.
>> Did she do any of these things or
>> Well, I don't know if it is I said I
said Biden or Harris.
>> No, I understand that. But I'm just
saying like the the the logic of blaming
Kamla for what happened in Gaza after
October 7th is so flimsy.
>> That's fine. That's fine. I'll grant
you. I don't I'm not I'm not going to
circle the drain on this. But then also
but then also but wait just you got to
let me talk too. I love you. You're my
boy.
>> Well, hang on. But but like I I I hope
these people see this guy. I hope these
people see this guy. He's like the
worst. He's actually like just
like a He's just a man. I don't know
what else to say. He does this.
It's It's actually crazy that he does
this. Okay. That's why Josiah is just
talking to Hutch's audience. Yeah. Yeah.
No, the you're my boy thing is you are
being condescending in a lot of cases,
right? It's it's it is condescending,
but I think I don't think Petco used it
on Hutch that much in person. Maybe he
did. I'm I'm trying to think of if he
did or not. It is condescending though.
And right here, I don't know why he
would say it to get him to stop talking.
>> Wait, wait, wait. But
>> wait, you got to let me talk, too. I
love you. You're my boy.
>> Well, hang on. But but but because we're
like Hutch Hutch didn't have an argument
here, right? Josiah literally pre-fired
his argument on Kamla. And then Hutch is
like, "But I'm still going to make that
same argument." He just wasn't
listening. Again, by the way, cuz Josiah
already knocked that argument down
before Hutch even gave that argument.
Josiah knocked it down and Hutch wasn't
paying attention. We're limited on time.
Can you concede that that that excuse
doesn't work for Biden? that Biden was
in charge and we still expected
Palestinian Americans to voted to vote
for Biden when he was the nominee.
>> Even then, I'm a little flimsy on it.
But like I told you, I I I I did not
give to there were a lot of clips of her
popping up on my feed, you know, on
Biden, calling him a genocide enabler.
And I told my chat at the time, I was
like, "Listen, I'm not going to lecture
this person. I'm frustrated by this, but
I'm not I just I'm just not going to
lecture someone in that spot." Um, but
even even then I I find it kind of
flimsy because Biden is not responsible
for how Israel conducted themselves
after that war. And uh then who is?
I'm going to go ahead and say that the
leader of the country providing them aid
and weapons and a security guarantee is
probably a little responsible. I I'm
sorry. I I hate to tell you, the United
States had some ability to control
Israel, to to inhibit Israel there, and
they did not use the leverage they had.
That's just factual. You don't like it,
that's okay, but that's just true.
>> Um, you know, it also involved Congress.
It was a bipartisan effort with
Republicans as well. But I don't think
it's I don't think it makes a lot of
sense to like blame him for how Israel
conducted themselves. And he his
administration did at many times
throughout that time period. um
influenced the Israelis in a positive
direction to allow humanitarian aid into
the country to evacuate Rafa before they
did that big offensive. And so I mean
you have to be kind of like really read
up on this stuff to understand that
which is why
>> I think he did a decent amount to try to
>> without inhibiting Israel significantly
slightly keep things a little more
optically safe. It didn't work and it
still went really badly. But he did do
some things.
But you just wouldn't make this argument
given where it went to. I don't think
you would ever make this argument. All
right. With other like sets of war
crimes, anything like this, I don't
think you'd go, "Well, actually, one
time they sent in like cookies for all
the people." Yeah. I don't Does that
matter? Is that like a significant
thing? Like cool. They they sent some
cookies in, but then a bunch of people
died still. A bunch of people starved.
bunch of people are left without homes
or clean food, clean water or food,
right?
>> That's like one of the reasons why I
didn't want to fight him on that. But,
you know, it's just a little it's a
little different for me to compare that
situation to a guy who, you know, had a
literal Nazi tattoo. And
>> yeah, it's hard to compare them because
obviously the Nazi tattoo is nowhere
near as bad. You bald [__]
>> Definitely lied about it. I'm not I I
agree with you. I don't think Grant
Platner is a Nazi. I do think that it's
possible.
If you don't think he's a Nazi, what is
the point of constantly saying, "He lied
about the tattoo. He lied about the
tattoo. He lied about the tattoo." Do
you not understand at all if Do you not
understand at all that when he goes when
you go, "He lied about the tattoo. He
lied about the What are you implying?
What are you What are you signaling to
people?"
Well, he definitely lied about the
tattoo. He had the tattoo for 15 years
and he definitely lied about it and like
I I don't know what what are we supposed
to do about that?
>> Come on, man. That he knew that it was a
Nazi tattoo, but but still got it
anyways because of the military
implications. Like he just wanted to
look like a big bad scary person or
whatever. Um but but he for sure lied
about knowing what it was after the
fact.
>> Okay, but you're not concerned. What
would be the concern if he was lying?
You want politicians who never lie, pick
a different planet.
Right? I think lying is bad. I think
lying over something totally
inconsequential from your personal life
is not as bad objectively. Especially
when it's weighed against a Senate seat.
Like come on, man. Right. Especially
it's you're you're talking about a
Senate seat. So you could say all of
this. You could say he lied about it.
Well, you If if he lied about it, then
what's the big deal? Well, he you know,
he got it not because he's a Nazi,
because he wanted to seem like a big
scary military guy. Okay, so what's the
problem? Well, he lied. All right. What
if Dude, there's got to be an example of
other lies like this, right? Other
totally totally tiny, minuscule lies
that nobody cares about that Hutch would
absolutely defend. I know this is the
case because he's a political operative
or he's a political streamer. He would
definitely do this in other cases.
Anyway, we keep going. And I just if I
put myself in the shoes of a person I
that would be a really tough pill for me
to swallow. And so for me and I'll
finish up here for me.
>> Hutch could you reiterate your core
point like four more times so maybe
Josiah understands it or hears it? You
think if you repeat it like a hundred
more times maybe he'll get it?
>> Me I think the strat is to just like let
that go. Just let it go. You know, like
we can do the m we can push blue no
matter who, but when it comes to like
this particular thing, I don't know if
it makes a lot of sense to be like
picking fights with.
>> So, I would just want to know where did
Hutch make an argument?
What is Hutch's argument?
Cuz this is a Nicholas Dioro argument.
Well, listen, man. You might be right,
and this could be true. Everything you
said could be true. But it just looks a
little weird to tell a guy not to be mad
about a Nazi tattoo. Did you think about
that? Did you think about how it's weird
to tell a American not to be mad about a
Nazi tattoo? It's like, yeah, but it's
the Senate and it's the it's the second
half of the Trump admin possibly still
maintaining a majority in the Senate.
It's possibly like the most
consequential race in the entire
midterms. Well, sorry, it has the
ability to be. Shouldn't be. What it
should be is the entire Democratic party
unifying behind Graham Platner so that
they can get control of the Senate,
right? And then the harder races should
be elsewhere. But it seems like
Democrats are determined to turn
uh Maine into a difficult seat to win. I
don't know why.
>> Americans who don't feel comfortable
with this guy. I kind of get why they
don't feel comfortable.
>> So So a couple of things here and again.
>> And by the way, nobody's saying you
should feel comfortable with this guy.
They're saying you should vote for this
guy and you should endorse this guy.
If you want to say tattoo
notwithstanding cuz I find that gross
and I I don't know that we've heard the
whole truth there. I absolutely endorse
this person because it's very important
that we that we gain regain control of
the Senate. Right. That's all you got to
say, man. It gets a little bit of your
little, you know, thing out there. It
gets a little bit of your like disavow
out there, but you still say obviously
we need to go ahead and vote for this
guy again. And we're pressed for time.
Um, yeah, I I am not I am not blaming
Joe Biden for everything that Israel
did. And I totally agree with you that
Joe Biden um used influence at various
points to try to blunt the extent of um
of Israel's crimes against Gaza and the
the the ruthlessness of the campaign. I
totally concede that. Now, what I don't
concede is this idea that Biden is
totally divorced. I do think that he had
agency and culpability in what followed,
and that is a consensus of the American
people. So, you know, whatever the
underlying fact of the matter is, the
perception, the widespread perception is
that Biden is partly to blame. Not
Netanyahu level, but he is partly to
blame and could have used his position
as the most powerful person in the world
to perhaps should firm to try to blunt
that, which you yourself can see. Number
one. Number two,
>> again, I I totally understand that it
would be a bitter pill to swallow. I I
agree with that. Um, but when I look at,
again, I'm just looking at it from the
vantage point of
>> Yeah. So, Josiah is like making points.
I I swear if if Hutch listens to this
and says something along the lines of I
hear what you're saying, man, but like
Nazi tattoo guy. I just Yeah. What What
are you going to do? I will lose it. I
will actually lose it. Of first a
platner and then a Palestinian American
with Biden or
>> There's no way, right? Graham Platner
had a Nazi tattoo and lied about it. I
agree with that. What you and I had this
conversation. I even publicly posted um
when I got read the riot act about this
and people that for me it was the Reddit
thread. Somebody linked me to a Reddit
thread where he was in a sub post under
the toteencom thing where it's just it's
it's really hard to imagine that he
didn't know what it was or didn't find
out about what it was after he had it
and didn't get rid of it. Right. versus
a Palestinian American who has reason to
believe that the one of the candidates
is facilitating a genocide that's orders
of magnitude worse. Like we would agree
with that, right? That having a Nazi
tattoo and lying about it is is is as is
terrible but is infinitely less bad than
facilitating or a genocide against your
family, your people. Right? We would
agree that those are two wildly
different things, right? Just from his
face. Just from his face alone, just
from his face alone, you could just tell
he's like
Nazi tattoo guy.
>> Yes. But again, I take
>> Okay. Wait, wait, wait. There shouldn't
There shouldn't even be There should be
no hesitation there. I don't have time
to litigate. I don't have time to
litigate that. So, I'll just take the
Yes.
>> Hey.
Fantastic, Moran. There should be no
That's just an obvious yes.
That's just an obvious yes. Come on,
man.
>> My point is there's some important
there's there's some important caveats
there, but okay, let's go.
>> Sure. Sure. Well, and we we can we can
hash that out.
>> Of course. Of course. Everybody in this
chat says no, it's not worse. No, it's
not worse. Is there a genocide? If it
were a genocide, nope. Nope. Off. No.
No. No. Fantasy. That didn't happen.
Nope. It's not a genocide.
Awesome. So awesome, man. You love to
see it. You love to see it. Now I'll
I'll pop in on the next episode of Live
and Learn where you can make the case to
me that actually Josiah is Josiah taking
lessons from Pisco.
Is Josiah taking lessons from Pisco in
terms of trying to have normal
intelligent conversations with Hutch and
failing because he lacks the capacity?
>> Yeah, he's taking lessons from Pisco.
Yeah, precisely. Precisely. Thank you.
>> A person who is not a Nazi having a Nazi
tattoo and lying about it is as bad or
worse.
>> Let's do that. You come on the next
episode.
>> We can we can we can have that
conversation. You can explain that to me
cuz that one I I'm baffled by that one.
But I'll take your I'll take your
reluctant. Yes. My point is I'm
consistent here and you're consistent.
That's really all that matters. You're
not having a special rule for Joe Biden
or a special rule for Graham Platner.
You're consistent. I get why a
Palestinian American wouldn't pull the
lever for Biden. I wasn't going to wag
my finger at Rashida Talib. I'm not
going to do it for Jake Aenclaus. That's
perfectly fair. I've got no smoke for
you. Um I do have smoke for people who
have the double standard. And I do have
smoke for Aenclaus just on my own lights
because again, he's not just a random
voter, a random American. He's part of
leadership. And again, unless you
genuinely believe that Graham Platner is
a Nazi and I don't think the evidence is
there, or if you said again, you know, I
I prefer Costello in the primary because
he's technically still in the primary.
He's not going to win it, but he's it's
it's a possibility, right? And um I
support him and I I back Josiah, please.
You're breaking our hearts. Stop
railroading Hutch. Bro, it's there.
Apparently Hutch now has an audience
that doesn't that sees him as like a
mental invalid. He He cannot be anything
but railroaded. If if anybody is ever
talking and saying something correct,
it's you're actually wrong for doing
that. You're wrong. You're wrong. You're
evil. Stop doing that. You know, I'll
support the Democratic nominee at Jay's
talk. What do you think is the real
reason Hutch or sorry, Josiah left Live
and Learn? He was smart. Lol. I know
what he said. And then I disagreed. I
disagreed that that was the reason.
He said he was just like busy and he
didn't have time for it. And in my head,
I'm like, dude, you that's like not a
commitment. That's like such a high
value commitment that like it's like an
hour or two a week. And I understand,
but realistically, you could do like one
less video, maybe. I think it was I
think it was having the cast come under
attack and that he was having to deal
with drama outside of the show that had
to do with the show. I think that's what
it was that he was just seeing that the
show was going to be used as like a
wedge between this group of people and
he just wanted no part of that. That's
what I think. But he didn't say that. He
said he just needed the time back. So,
uh, who am I to tell him he's lying?
Man, whoever that may be, I'm cool with
that, too. But that's not what Aenclaus
said. So, I'm I'm very easy to please.
I'm not saying that Aenclaus had to get
down on one knee and say, "Yes, sir,
Graham Platner. Um, I will I will I will
hold your hand and campaign uh with you
in Maine." And that's not what I'm
asking for. I'm just asking as a leader
of of the the coalition trying to get a
Democratic majority in the Senate, um
that he just say he's going to back the
Democratic nominee, whoever it is. And
if he wants to state a preference for
Costello, that would have been fine.
That's it.
>> All right. All right. All right. We are
going on to the next time stamp.
>> So people are calling this guy an Israel
first Democrat. And I think that's fair.
>> I mean that's not even a subtle
anti-semitic trope there. Move to
Israel, Jake. Telling a American Israel
playing into like a a decadesl long
trope of dual loyalty. Like not even a
subtle anti-semitic trope at the end
there.
>> Move to Israel, Jake. So people are
calling this guy in
>> an abundance, bro. Oh my goodness. Get
him out of here. Send him to Israel.
Israel first Democrat. And I think
that's fair. I think that's fair. In
fact, uh, he's taken a colossal
>> I think it's fair to call him an Israel
first
>> colossal amount of money from the Israel
lobby.
>> Bro, he literally he fought in
Afghanistan. This is a veteran, a
military veteran
that he's accusing of being Israel
first. Like they don't they're not even
I don't think Kyle is an anti-semite,
but holy. How about this one? Throwback
to when Jake Alen Claus was in hot water
for old Facebook post about burning the
Quran. Look at this. I'm sorry for 20110
Facebook post about burning the Quran.
>> Wait, are we using are we using old
social? I just need to be clear on the
rules. Okay. Are we using old social
media?
>> Well, you can't do that. He said this on
Twitter already. This is one of his
Twitter bangers. Oh, are we going to use
social media post to cancel people?
>> Post to disqualify people.
>> No, it's to look at his beliefs, right?
I think Graham Platner will say what he
does and doesn't believe. I guess you'd
have to look at a Claus and say, "Well,
what does he believe here, right?"
>> Yes or no. Because if we're doing that,
boy is this awkward in the context of
this conversation.
>> Boy, is this ever awkward. Also, um
>> I never looked into the full actual post
of this.
>> Jesus,
>> I'm sorry for 2010 Facebook post about
burning Quran.
>> I was told to actually look at the post
for this.
Um facing mounting criticism from his
Democratic primary rivals, Newton uh
city councelor Jake Aenclaus on
Wednesday formally apologized for a
decade old social media post alluding to
burning the Quran. Aenclaus, who is who
was viewed as a front runner in the race
to replace Congressman Joe Kennedy,
wrote in a 2010 Facebook post, "So we
can't burn their book, but they can burn
our flag." He linked to an article about
Pakistani lawyers earning the American
flag initially described the comment as
a sarcastic remark he made uh this stop
short of apologizing his rivals pounced
blah blah blah blah I mean it's not like
not terrific but
>> based on
>> we will get to this I'm trying to figure
out what do I want to put in the middle
of these things I think I'll do some
clips here real quick but I will I will
want to put something in the middle of
Hutch before we get into the Hutch
review of all of this okay uh yo Dickers
Thank for the raid on kick. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. I see you covered
the the Connor stuff today. We're going
to go over the Hutch review of that
shortly.
>> Done the reaction. I was I I I was
expecting much much worse. Okay,
>> we're doing some politics. So this guy,
who actually is in league, by the way,
when he does like this, sorry, it's
true, but you're in league with white
supremacist and Nazis. Okay, you did
that.
>> Careful now, Kyle. Careful. Careful.
>> But Platner's tattoo is unacceptable.
Number one, even though he got it
covered up. Number two, even though it
was a skull.
>> Even though he got it covered up. Holy
[__] man. I the whole Platner this
whole Platner arc I just feel so gaslit
by these people. Oh, you think having a
Nazi tattoo for over a decade and only
getting it removed right before a new
story came out about it. You think
that's bad? What about a old Facebook
post from 2010 where you said uh
something about burning the Quran
because somebody was burning an American
flag? Oh my god. Okay.
>> He didn't realize was a Nazi symbol.
Okay. Number three already for it.
Anyway,
>> read the tweet. Israel first damn. Hold
on, hold on, hold on.
>> Oenclaus, hello. What was that? That was
a primer for Reuben Rubin. Thank you so
much, Reuben. Ruben, for the primer.
Oenclaus led a letter to Rubio in
September calling US allies to who
recognized Palestinian statehood
performative and calling on the Trump
admin to work against them. His pack is
a primary backer of McMorro even though
Stevens was on his letter. And Angie
Craig, weird guy. Sounds like a weird
guy. I don't think it's weird to call
him an Israel first dem based on based
on that. Really?
>> He crossed a line whereas you everybody
should forgive you. Of course, right. No
joke. There we go.
>> There's no way he's being serious right
now. There's no way. There's no way he's
being serious about like a Facebook post
from a 22-year-old in 2010. Specifically
that Facebook post is worse than getting
a Nazi tattoo. It's still It's just so
absurd. It's so absurd. You kind of have
to laugh at it. It's kind of funny. Like
it is it's kind of funny. This whole
This whole situation is just like it's
like a It's like a It's like a Saturday
Night Live skit. I don't It's just uh
he's taken $915,000 from pro-Israel
packs. So that's the real reason why
he's against Grand Platter. If Grant
Platter had the same tattoo, he was pro-
Israel, Jake Alouch would be endorsing
him no problem whatsoever. No questions
asked. None.
>> Why would you just assume that? That's a
crazy thing to assume. I do feel like
we're kind of diving into some
anti-semitism here. Is it okay to say
that? This feels anti-semitic uh to make
these kinds of assumptions. Uh but since
he has that
>> I don't think Hutch is intellectually
equipped to discern that based on him
looking up all that person's statements
and and not understanding any of them. I
just actually think he's like
fundamentally he's at an IQ deficit. He
is too low IQ to really make the
determination at any point in time. He
does that cuz he's he's uh dancing for
scraps right now. You know, he's he's
jiggling the he's jingling the jar. Give
me a couple bucks, guys. Come on. Isn't
this anti-semitic? Come on. and puts
some money in the jar. Put some money in
the jar.
>> Or he did in the past, doesn't anymore.
Uh, and he's critical of Israel because
of their genocide. Well, that now it's
unacceptable. Now I'm going to do an
effective endorsement of Susan Collins.
Are you kidding me? Now,
>> effective endorsement is doing a lot of
leg leg work here,
>> by the way. Yes.
No, it's Does he not understand
effective endorsement is when you say
something's doing a lot of leg work, you
you point to the adjective effective or
something would be what's doing the leg
work there. If you wanted to make that,
you can't say the whole thing. You can't
say the entire thing is doing a lot of
lifting. When you say that, it's saying
that one. You're hiding all the
complexity of the issue behind like one
term like effective, right? That's what
you mean by it's doing a lot of heavy
lifting. It is your entire argument is
is summed up by the one word you're
using. You can't take the whole
statement and say it's doing heavy
lifting. No, that's their whole
statement. He continues, "As I said
months ago, I find planners not tattoo
in his commentary about it personally
disqualifying. If it were me, I'd vote
for someone else in the main Democratic
primary. He's He's the nominee. It's
over. It's done. Regardless of what
>> that didn't stop whatever
>> happens to me. Democrats need to
>> Yeah, but do you which side do you want
to be on? Kyle is on your side now. Kyle
started this video off by saying I
understand blue no matter who. It's
weird that these people don't. And now
instead of saying right, Kyle, this guy
should be blue no matter who. You're
going Kyle, don't you remember how you
were blue no matter who? That's how Kyle
started the video off saying I reallyed
up and I'll keep it. What a sick joke.
What a sick joke. So I said resign.
people are uh showing here. Look how
much money you've taken from the Israel
lobby. And this is why you'd be
comfortable with Susan Collins and not
with Gran Platter because he's not
taking any money from the Israel lobby.
Uh Ron Filicowsky says, "You said his
tattoo is personally disqualifying and I
hope Maine voters agree with me. One,
there are two choices in the race. Two,
the race could decide the Senate. Three,
your statement will be in lots of GOP
ads. It already is, by the way. It
already is. Four, nobody in Maine wants
anyone in Massachusetts to tell us what
we should do." Shout out to Ron Philip,
man of Minus Hutch. He's awesome. Where
where is what does Hutch have for
disagreement here? Like like okay Tommy
Vtor, Ron Philipowski and Richard
Hanania really running the gamut here
all agree that this is an endorsement of
Susan Collins. Why does this bald not
agree? What does this bald see that
these actually respected political
commentators don't? Did somebody help?
>> Awesome. Uh Tom, have you called her mil
to discuss it? Talking about you haven't
even talked to planner. You're just
endorsing against him. I wonder why that
is. Could it be because you take a
gazillion dollars in Israel lobby money
and he's critical of Israel and critical
of genocide and you support genocide? Is
that why? Is that it? Is that something
to do with it? You die at maga prick.
>> Oh my god. All right. I think we're done
with that. God damn it, man.
>> No. No response. Zero response.
>> And then people say like, "Well, Kyle's
on the team now." Well, is he though? I
don't. That seems dubious to me.
>> These are all people who are on Well,
sorry. Tommy Vtor and Ron Philowski are
on the team. Yes. The team is calling
this stupid. Why are you not on the
team, Hutch? The entire team is calling
this stupid, man. Wake up.